[Music]
if you wish to make an apple pie from
scratch you must first invent the
universe thank you very much that was
Carl Sagan talking in the really great
serious cosmos if you haven't seen it
then I really recommend that you check
it out they've done a modern reboot of
cosmos with neil degrasse tyson but the
original series still has some really
good gems in it like the one I just
showed you
so Sagan has a point if you wanted to
make an apple pie from scratch you would
need to first invent the universe so
let's just have a little tour of what
might be necessary to do that so we're
going to go back 13.8 billion years to a
singularity we're going to go back to
the Big Bang and this is a time when the
universe had infinite density and
temperature in at a finite time we know
about the Big Bang and this expected
singularity because of the fact that we
know the universe is now expanding and
we know that it's expanding at an
accelerating rate that's what Brian
Schmidt won the Nobel Prize for in 2011
and fun fact Brian Schmidt is now the
vice-chancellor of my University the AMU
so let's have a look at what this Big
Bang is going to look like I've made
something here on universe sandbox that
vaguely resembles a singularity but of
course that's going to be very hard for
me to show in reality so what I've done
here is I've taken an entire galaxy and
I've smushed it down to one point so all
of the mass in that galaxy is confined
to this
very bright patch at this point in the
early birth of the universe the
temperature would have been extremely
high
after the initial expansion the universe
would start to cool sufficiently to
allow the formation of subatomic
particles and later atoms leading to the
matter we see around us today elementary
particles like electrons protons and
neutrons would have decayed and combined
to form matter and then cooled forming
an early soup if you will of our
universe this will be the sauce and
apple pie is it's what we're going to
need to start with here so all of these
stars and galaxies formed through the
Big Bang are eventually going to lead to
the formation of us as well and we're
pretty important to be able to make this
apple pie
so another pretty famous quote from Carl
Sagan is this one surface the earth is
the shore of the cosmic ocean
on this Shore we've learned most of what
we know recently we've waded a little
way out maybe ankle-deep and the water
seems inviting some part of our being
knows this is where we came
we long to return and we can't because
the cosmos is also within us we're made
of starstuff
we are away the cosmos to know itself
the fact that we're made of starstuff is
pretty beautiful and I want to show you
what a supernova looks like because that
is where a lot of the elements are going
to be formed many of the more common
elements are made through nuclear fusion
and the cores of stars however not all
elements are made in the cause of
ordinary stars because nuclear fusion
reactions that make elements heavier
than iron require more energy than they
give off such reactions don't occur
under the stable conditions of nuclear
reactions and typical stars on the other
hand supernovae are not stable so this
is where a lot of the elements are made
or all of the elements that are heavier
than iron so let's have a look at the
birth of some of these very heavy
elements so I'm going to show you a
supernova type 1a and in the simulation
a white dwarf star
is going to accrete or gain material
from a nearby mess until its mass
exceeds the limit which triggers a
supernova to happen
so here's the white dwarf gaining
material and it's exploding in a
supernova where it's giving off the I
guess the elements that are going to go
out and the elements that are formed
here in the supernova are going to go
out and form other things whether it's
planets and maybe one of those planets
is earth so the materials that we see
all around us the materials that we're
going to need for our apple pie
some of them would come from a supernova
explosion like this some of the atoms
that make up you are the elements that
make up you are coming from explosions
just like this one so it's a pretty
incredible way to think about where we
actually come from taking it a little
bit little back down to earth we've come
back to the solar system so this might
have been formed from a disk of material
whether it was from coalescing material
from remnants of the Big Bang of
elements from the core of supernovae all
of that's contributed to give us what we
know and love today so let's find earth
and this is where we're going to make
our apple pie so it's pretty dark we're
coming in and out of nighttime here
depending on our rotation many of you I
know no matter where you are on the
earth might be studying for exams right
now or be in uni and working towards
something working towards being a
scientist or or someone that's curious
and can go out there and and make
discoveries or do cool things so there's
one last Sagan quote that I wanted to
finish this video with and it relates to
the idea that out there are incredible
things waiting to be known I showed you
a little bit of our incredible origin
and things that go into making us but
there is so much that we still don't
understand and even like what I told you
now is such a small portion of what
there is to learn about where we came
from so I want this to be a little bit
of am good luck and keep going to all
the people who are out there studying
just keep working towards those things
keep working towards those goals of
discovery because there is so much out
there waiting for you to find out our
own planet is only a tiny part of the
vast cosmic tapestry a starry fabric of
worlds yet untold